where I was with alcohol I was in the
middle I was drinking no more than my
peers was I drinking too much absolutely
but so is the rest of the planet that's
the point had I reached the point where
there was a rock bottom moment
absolutely not had it affected my career
not really was I in trouble at home not
really but I was still drinking too much
and that's the message I'm trying to get
across because then people have to
listen they have to stand up and listen
because actually I'm talking to them I'm
not talking now to the people that have
got maybe dependency issues and all
those type of things I'm aiming it right
in the middle this mid lane malays of
people saying look going out cold free
will be the best thing that you've ever
done taking a break in the booze take it
from me or just transform your life in
so many ways and people almost can't get
their head around this but my point is
this if you want to be an even better
athlete take a break from outcome
guaranteed if you want to be an even
better parent take a break from outcome
guarantee an even better entrepreneur
and Even's the key word I'm not saying
you're not a great athlete or a great
parent but you will be even better when
you take a break from outcome fact